sorry Kwanzaa waalaikumsalam are you
doing pretty good
let's have a cut looking to come here
okay imagine you've got imagine
something here okay imagine you going to
John Mayer yeah okay I'm almost a few
you can have whatever you like yeah yeah
what is one thing that you will ask for
I can gently imagine you can have
everything you want
even an integer in each other each other
okay so what is do you brahim you can
have anything you like
yes reciting your family happiness
o'clock what is one thing that you
prefer one thing that you would
personally want in general I was going
to say you can have whatever you like
here why is one thing by even ask for
one of the his speeches policy whatever
is going through his mind these pieces I
would say I want to get I want to get
everything ok one thing one more thing
one thing that you really want going
still on just one just one of these boys
want a nice one one mazing value what I
would want think about it
let me know any readier
all the what is one thing or maybe two
things
thank you for one this is something
special just what is one I don't know
like maybe what would you write
everything like 41 on a whole collection
[Music]
which was one of the parables I don't
mind I would like a big house
this may help you a big house witness a
Lamborghini and then I want I'm sorry I
would really have a limp again sorry too
much and I'm beginning to yes
and then I would have houses for my
grandparents Allen table cut is so
you're gonna have Holly's come over
talking different you know what somebody
Tiffany I want to find dinosaur oh I was
gonna like that anything I mean anything
okay I want to fly I'm gonna blow it
yeah where you gonna play friendly sky
you're gonna play with yourself
Oh buddy what at me like no one ever way
no well if I could have a wife not an
assistant and there's a food what what
kind of it really difficult burgers
pizza chicken barbecue chicken and ps4
here for you with great FIFA signs and
console all the mobile phones and
PlayStation they're very expected
anything else money and money for one
let's have money
Michael's mom exam one is library
effects or something like all the books
I've ever wanted to read but they get
the chance
well anything else you know what
somebody PLO dinner to food what kind of
food
I'm also some quick looks definitely you
want Chris remember yeah which we can
also vinegar
dinner yep now on our rivers and rivers
a walk Chocola well are you I probably
want a really big house
yeah made of what gold made a gold yeah
I'm diamonds one room house and then I
like the whole interior to be made out
of diamonds we're going to go now I can
play
can i play video games in heaven okay
you wanna get there anyway love it yes
what about you watch my lesson and I can
get cos well massive mansion were you
gonna do in the one soon maybe 100 house
ten times center why you're going to run
around a bunch of different and I just
having fun with the space looking better
make the rest of it general most of all
invite us in Honolulu Hawaii informal
one country let that initially one
Anamosa warranty renewed one Olympian
equally tomorrow volunteer meeting
unusually generous even appear to never
be